هذا هو هذا أعني أن هذا مثير جدًا لدرجة
أنه ترك كل شخص آخر
الآن فجأة في طريقه وهذا
إنجاز مذهل هذان
المعززان الجانبيان اللذان جعلهما يتفوقان على
الغلاف الجوي أولئك الذين طافوا بالفعل في
الفضاء بمجرد استخدامهم و
وقد يكونون قد هبطوا أو لا يكونون قد هبطوا في
المرحلة الثالثة ولكن المفتاح الحقيقي هو أننا الآن نتمكن من
الوصول إلى الفضاء لأن نكون قادرين على
وضع الأقمار الصناعية في مدار حول العالم ولكن
الأشياء الثقيلة مثل القمر أو المريخ
الآن بتكلفة أرخص بكثير مما كانت تستخدمه
أن يكون
الأمر أشبه بالذهاب ، لا أعرف
ربما من المراوح إلى المحركات النفاثة
بقدر ما يأخذنا إلى عالم جديد من
القدرات ، إنها خطوة كبيرة والقيام
بذلك في المحاولة الأولى نعم إنه مندهش تمامًا